♪♪
Merry Christmas, everyone. Love
you all!
-All the best, Nathan.
-Yeah, love you too, mate.
-Don't ever change, Nate.
Oi! Before you go, I have one
more Christmas surprise for you.
All:
It's Roy!
-Yeah, yeah.
One of my presents
to Keeley is that I'd stop by
and say (bleep) Merry Christmas to you lot.
So, Merry (bleep) Christmas.
Ted:
Well, jingle my bells, it's Roy
Kent.
-(Gasp)
What's the matter?
I got something on my face?
Rebecca:
No, Ted. That's the problem.
There's nothing on your face.
Your mustache is gone.
Ahhhhh!
♪Yeah, it might be all that you
get♪
♪♪
♪Yeah, I guess this might well
be it♪
♪♪
♪And heaven knows I've tried♪
Quick, anyone got a mirror?
Here you go, Coach. I've always
got a mirror.
Oh, no. I'm supposed to
FaceTime with Henry in an
hour.
He won't recognize me without my
mustache.
It's gonna ruin Christmas.
Don't worry, Ted. We're on it.
Everyone, split up and find that
snot mop!
♪♪
Boy, I hope they find it.
I really wanted this Christmas
to be perfect.
Higgins:
Sorry, Ted.
We looked everywhere.
Yes, I searched every inch of
the Royal Opera House.
It wasn't in Ted's car.
But I don't have a car, Jamie.
Then is wasn't in the person's
car whose window I just smashed
with a rock.
People, we don't need to find
Ted's mustache. We need to catch
it.
I built a trap and baited it
with a mustache's favorite
things:
crumbs, a small comb and a tiny
bit of pomade.
Nate, that's a kill trap.
You're damned right it is.
That thing escaped from Ted's
face,
who knows what it wants next?
Keeley:
Wait!
Before we kill anything, let me
try something.
(Wheels squeaking)
(Zips)
(Lights pop on)
-Oh, little more up there.
-And a little just there and
presto!
Oh, I love it.
I-I don't know, guys.
It's not really me, you know?
Looks more more like Clark
Gable or John Waters.
Allow me.
Why do you have a disguise kit?
Why don't you?
-That's amazing.
-Looks just like him.
-I think you look fantastic.
Agree to agree, but the whole
point is for Henry to recognize
me.
Right, forgot the objective.
(Tears)
-Yowzer!
Oi! You need a 'tache? Here.
(Tearing)
(Grunting)
(Bop)
Whoa, I look like Detroit Tigers
super-fan, Magnum PI.
But even though this feels like
I'm kissing your forehead,
it ain't me Roy.
Oh babe, I'm gonna miss your
eyebrows.
Hang on.
(Gasp)
You're so hairy.
Disgusting.
Aye, it's no use. For the first
time in history, Tom Selleck has
ruined Christmas.
I'll see y'all tomorrow.
Where will he go? What will he
do?
Frankly my dear, I don't give a
damn.
-Wow!
-Is that Clarke Gable?
That is just right.
Aww, thank you. Obviously I do
care, it's just the mustache
talking.
♪♪
(Chime)
Keeley:
We love you, Ted.
(All greeting Ted)
Hey guys, sorry I was being such
a straight, white, cisgender
male version of the Grinch earlier.
Which I guess is just Ebenezer
Scrooge.
Rebecca:
Don't be silly, Ted.
Higgins: Oh, don't worry about that.
Ted:
But I realized not having my
mustache, it ain't the end of the world.
'Cause it's not about making
Christmas perfect for the people
you love,
it's the people you love that
make Christmas perfect.
Higgins:
That is amazing, I can't believe
my eyes.
Rebecca: Oh my gosh.
Uh-oh, what's wrong now?
Keeley:
Your mustache is back.
-Hot dog, eggnog!
(Chime)
Uh-oh, that's Henry. I'll see
y'all later.
All: Good luck, Ted! Bye!
Henry:
Merry Christmas, Dad.
You look great.
Thanks, buddy. I actually just
shaved.
You know what? One second big guy!
Hey, everyone. Have a perfect
Christmas.
I-I mean, an imperfect
Christmas. 'Cause it's the
imperfections that make it,
well, I mean you get it. You saw
what we're going for, right?
Uh-oh! Is it snowing in my
apartment? Huh, that's weird.
♪♪